you know uh one of our lps told me in
the past
that impacts is no excuse for bad
businesses
and i think it's even more than that
because
being a mission-driven company that
found
brought money from impact investors or
mission-driven investors
you need to prove
more than others that you are able to
scale the company
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by home adventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctec
let's talk about doing good and what
better than the good company meet
shachar botsel the co-founder and
managing partner of good company
he is the father of four and one of
israel's first and leading impact
investors he's the co-founder managing
partner at good company vc emission
driven early stage vc fund he's held
various leading positions in the
business and social sectors among others
as managing partner at 2b community and
is the chairman at east alliance a
publicly traded holding company
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
thanks thank you so much for thank you
for inviting me here thank you for
having me it's a beautiful beautiful
office space good company vc
you know i think that you know
immediately as you're looking at looking
at your profile looking at the companies
you've invested in and your involvement
with the industry in so many different
organizations both in volunteering and
investing
it's
very clear that you've understood that
your vision is to be an impact investor
and to do good for the world while also
doing great business and i'm excited to
get to know you better so tell me tell
me a little bit about yourself so i'm 29
i have four kids what are their names um
nevo yanai
arad and daria
darya is only three months three months
old wow a girl after four or four three
boys so that's like
a big thing
and i'm
i'm investor the vc
the managing partner in good company
that's my
professional id for the past
almost eight years
i've been doing it before in
to be community and now in good company
that we started two years ago
but i think that if i need to say who i
am i'm i'm more seeing myself as a
change maker
so i'm happened to doing it by
the business sector and the tech
industry and early stage
because i believe that's where my talent
is but my passion
is creating positive change
being a change maker
before we talk about business and talk
about investments
where how do you see the world from your
lenses why
why do we need a change maker
in your perspective
so i think my my point of view on the
business sector really
shifted in the past few years
i started more like in the optimistic
version of impact investor it came i
came from a background of both
social sector and business sector for a
few years and then i had the opportunity
that your cheshire invited me to join
him and start to be community
and and i think both of us were in the
place of of thinking that every business
can be an impact business
um
and
putting a lot of emphasize on on
measuring
and and like the way that the business
measure his social or environmental kpi
there
i think it shifted once because i've
done it like a lot of times i'm doing
been doing it since 2014. wow and
investing i've only started hearing
about impact investing i think maybe in
2019 yeah and when we started and we we
i went like meeting a potential investor
also
or entrepreneur saying like impact
investor
people they think your philanthropist is
just giving out money ask me who should
they donate
most of them but we did found people who
believed in us and gave us the
opportunity of course
um there it was mostly your land
and after doing it for already more than
almost 15 companies
being the first investor and a board
member and working with the
entrepreneurs
i understood that they are the big
opportunity at least in my perspective
is the place
places where there's like a single
bottom line another double bottom line
what does that mean
like instead of looking for companies
who
can show you like their business kpis
and then a separate slide how will we
measure our effect on climate or effect
on social
issue
uh
we are looking now in good company and
companies that their product
and if they have like we call it north
stark api
single kpi of the business will also
indicate that they are solving
a problem either climate problems so
it's
aligned and then there's a line and then
you can really help those
the founders to build their business and
not be in the place that
impact is an excuse for bad business or
something like that so just to make sure
that i understand if we forward those
you know you would see that you had you
know a slide saying okay this is our
business model but then this is the
secondary kpi because we're also going
to be doing good by xyz you're saying no
no what we're focusing on is we want we
want those two things to be on the same
slide to be in the same sentence we are
this is a north star and that north star
is all is the one that is creating this
positive impact right yeah i believe
that's the the play the scale of like an
impact perspective
i'm not sure it's a profession but this
perspective of
of being in like
impact in mission-driven
vc
the scale is in those spaces
of course there will only always be room
for philanthropy and there will always
be room also for csr and companies that
are just selling like something that you
can be sustainable but you can't really
change the world with and you do need to
have like your perspective and how do
you affect your employees the
environment and and the community
but i think the scale of impact
perspective in business
is in those places that are looking for
the world's biggest problem
in the next 20 years and trying to solve
them through technology
so if you're when you're looking at a
company and you're looking at an
entrepreneur you're about to embark on a
journey with them as a pre-seated
investor right and you know really first
check first meaningful check into the
company
how do you even gauge you know this
added extra layer of complexity because
it's hard enough to create a good
business it's much harder to create a
good business that as a north star is
also creating positive impact how do you
go about even rationalizing with the
entrepreneur through all the different
risks and the added complexity here so
actually what we're trying to do is to
work the opposite we are starting from
the y
so in good company our like method or
our way of operating
is
first what we do is we work with
multinational corporates
then we're trying to reverse the legit
uh reverse logistic the vc industry so
we're working as a corporate vc but for
multi multinational corporations
in the field that we are specializing
which is agriculture digital health
future of work
and um circular economy that says
standard supply chain energy stuff like
that
and we're working with them to map where
are their
climate or social crisis ahead
that can we can be the billion dollar
company around or
more than a billion
and then we study the market we study
the competition and we go and we look
for israeli founders who sold that
proactively okay so usually when we'll
meet with a entrepreneur with the
founder
we will come already educated about the
market and about the competition and we
know what we are looking for
it's much easier and the product itself
is solving an issue right so there's no
need we don't even need to discuss
the mission
how does a board meeting run when you're
both looking at business and impact at
the same time and and you're not not
just measuring the business group but
you're also measuring you know hardcore
kpis on on you know affecting positive
change how does how does a meeting like
that look like so the things the the the
companies we invested in good company
they have
in our perspective single bottom line
single kpi
we're working
before investing with the founders to
understand what is this kpi especially
in the early stage when you need to be
super focused can you give me an example
of the of a single of a single line kpi
yeah sure so a big hero that you know we
invested there together
so they are saving bees by saving bees
they are lodging pollination by that
making more yield in the field we are
measuring their like our perspective as
good companies measuring how many acres
do they serve
the more acres they will serve the more
money they will make right but the more
money they will make more bids they will
save right so there's no need to have
separate
kpis what i experienced in the past
years
is companies that have separate kpis
and then you have what called mission
drift so either
a very like big vc from
from
the u.s who is not impacted in any way
invest and he says like
they're not in the board anymore i don't
care about that slide i don't want to
see it anymore so then the company
slowly starts to drift from the from the
mission
the other
option is that the company doesn't
succeed to bring
follow-on investors which means
the business is not
going very well
and then usually they will speak a lot
about this slide of social
social impact okay that makes a lot of
sense
how do you know to differentiate
between because today everybody wants to
do good and practically imagine every
company
feels the need to explain that what
they're doing is making a positive
change in the world so how do you now in
20 approaching 2022 know to
differentiate those that are actually
making a positive impact versus those
that are that are saying they want to
make a positive impact but really it's
it's not you know not the same
not the same thing
so i think first of all
uh it's becoming mainstream
and that's a positive thing like we we
we like that it's we hear more
more vcs talking about mission driven
and
we see it as a positive thing and and
we think that will help also
the areas that we invest in that will
help them evolve and that's also part of
what we're doing in the movement in our
missions that we're doing at the corner
that's start of bringing more
more funds more multinational
cooperation more corporate funds
to co-invest with us and to work with us
in the companies i think
that what we do is because we are
starting from the y
and we know what we want to solve
so naturally it's all about the people
like it's it's early stage so you you
can't really know who will succeed and
you can't really know what will be even
the indications of succeeding because
the product is going to change and the
go to market is going to change right so
what you do is exactly what you do in
the business side of the tech side
you talk with the founders and you try
to see how do they think right like you
don't you go to their assumptions
trying to
challenge them
see how do they think why do they do it
what they
why did they decide
this problem why not another problem
right why not to take this technology
and use it in another use case which
will not be
impactful right
if you're
taking me back to 2014 when you're
starting out you're looking at
2b and you're you're thinking about
impact investing what happened like why
why going to impact investing at a time
when nobody really is talking about it
and and it's not mainstream
why is this such a big part of you
so i think i have a unique uh
um
cv
of being in like a few micro careers
in very various fields until i find
myself as a investor which is actually
like mentoring investing strategic
planning those are the qualities that
you need
understanding about people those
qualities that you need as an investor
but it took me time to find myself
there so in a way my career started at
the age of
wow filed a an appeal to the supreme
court because the
red school the the
city that i grew up wasn't accessible
and there was a legal precedent on my
name it was like foreign actually
yeah and wow that's something that
helped a lot of people with disabilities
to enter the system the regular system
why did you file the appeal and people
before you did it didn't
what what was different there
i think it's mainly my parents uh
and the credit i think is mainly for
them like my father represented me there
in front of the supreme court where
though he wasn't a lawyer then actually
yeah my mother is maybe a lioness
and i think it's that's the
the the difference in a way like they
wouldn't accept any other option but
me being completely independent wow
and
and i think that's something that not
every boy at the age of 13
find himself like in in that in that
kind of
in this change breaking the ends and
seeing like
everyone around you said that you can do
something and you decide that you can
and you're changing it
so that was probably
something that
like affected me in a significant way
and then i was in the army in in
computers volunteering
for two and a half years and then
i started accounting and economy which i
don't know why i did
and
then afterwards i was the chairman of
the of the student union
yeah and then i did a few
positions both in the social sector and
this and the business sector
and not tech and
and when i met you and he was looking
for somebody who speaks both languages
both of us didn't know the world impact
investing but
i think the more interesting thing to
discuss is like
the journey of starting good company
after understanding
like what works and what doesn't work
and also i must say that good company is
not an impact
a vc
we don't call ourself an impact we see
we are a mission driven vc okay and we
are a vc that starts from the y and we
are very proactive and
we have a lot of like
um
difference about us we but we don't use
the word
impact because i think it says to a lot
of people something different
than the way we work and what are we
looking to
to invest in and to back
tell me about the story of the founding
of good company
so
actually i i had an amazing experience
in to be an amazing home
amazing place to work and
and
the fun was already at the end of of the
investment period that we did already
that location
and then a euro decided that he don't
want to fundraise another fantasy
gp prefer to be an lpn and we started
discussing will i stay in the
family fund or i'll go out and then the
corona started
and i was for 11 months at home
because i'm at risk
and it's like
a big opportunity to listen to yourself
and what do you really want
and i had indoor my partner and my
friend
now
and if we already became friends but we
we knew each other as colleagues
he came from technology he came like i
come from more for the economy side
he comes from technology
he
was at the sapio and f2
and he started looking at more
meaningful things to invest in
and he was the first
one to jump in and say i'm leaving f2
i'm starting a fan come let's do it
together wow
and against all odds because we didn't
have any coil lp
and we like we had nothing
with this and a lot of people told us
it's too early
let's like go work in another fight be a
partner in another fan
wait it's not the top but we said this
is the timing like i
i felt watching at the deal flow from
2014 you told me that you only heard of
it in 2019 so think
in 2014 it was really hard to find
like first step founders
who wants to build something in energy
or agriculture or digital heads it
wasn't easy to find them
and even if you found them it was really
we really had to convince them
to take money from you when you're like
saying i'm an impact investor
because they say okay but what do you
understand in arctic what are you
understanding like what do you
understand what i do i need to help in
what's in
with customers with talent with
and going forward
to to to coffee like
march
the deal flow were amazing like i saw
companies
and i wasn't investing so like to be
commenting already finishing the
investment period and i said like this
is the timing even though everything is
happening
so we just left like a door left f2 i
left to be
very good relationship with both funds
and we just started investing our own
money
so we did the
five investment in warehousing
before starting uh bringing other lp's
and then
now we already have seven companies and
we did our first closing and moving
forward it's like an amazing journey
and i think in a way we can also discuss
it both of us
had experienced it a
fundraising your own fund
also makes you a better investor i think
why do you think so
i think though and me both of us were
always good company
for our
founders and i think that's like our
main asset
is what founders that we work with to
like think about us
but even though until you don't
do the process of fundraising yourself
meeting like 300 potential
investors having like no after no after
maybe afternoon
and then getting a yes
you don't really understand what what's
the experience of
the roller coaster of being a founder
and you maybe you can do it like
technically
you answer on time and you give
like
you you always do what you promise but
it's not the same
experiencing the other side they're very
similar to building your own startup
very similar very very similar and i
love how you're looking at the the
timeliness of of good company because it
sounds like it was both timeliness in
terms of of what was happening around
the world this awakening of first-tier
entrepreneurs going into energy and
aggregate and agritech and and all those
different sectors that are more
considered impact traditionally
but now with them obviously with a
mission-driven approach
but also timely in terms of your own
personal experience and where you're at
and your understanding of who you are
and what you're ready for yeah and it
sounds and it sounds incredible yeah we
had a feeling that we are in the right
place like people like in the ideation
just did an exit want to do their next
startup in in energy
and they're in the ideation coming to
meet us telling us like what do you
think about that and we had opportunity
to go and support them support them in
the precede encouragement
right now
the market is flooded with money like
you so you spoke about it with a few
people in the
in the podcast but i think there are
still
a few areas who are underserved
especially in the pre-seed seed
and and we are we have a good position
in the market
to enter those deals
the
number one
or one of the top tips you would give to
an entrepreneur
that is starting their business
wants to be impact driven
wants to be mission driven
wants to also be very profitable
what is you know one of the top things
that you would tell them
to to think about or to focus on as
they're ideating and as they're going
through their process
so i think it's i'm going to like try to
squeeze two advices in one i'll allow it
the israeli way
but i think like
build it as you fly
like don't try to over plan over
research over meet the market as soon as
possible
and learn as you fly as you're building
the startup
but be focused and building the business
and not building the founding that the
the the rounds yeah i think there's an
issue right now in the market because
there's a lot of money looking to invest
that it confused founders
and there are two focus in building the
rounds
and not focused enough in building the
product the business
and building the the startup is not it's
like building the team right
it's deciding who are your customers who
shouldn't be your customers
and and making sure that like the first
customers
you you get their feedback and you adapt
the product properly
and
i think like building it as you fly
focus on the business
and i'm saying it
this will help also the impact happen
like being focused on the business
is also the thing that's going to make
you mission driven
and
if you do focus on the impact
you know uh one of our lp's told me in
the past
that impacts is no excuse for bad
businesses
and i think it's even more than that
because
being a mission-driven company that
found
brought money from impact investor or
mission-driven investors
you need to prove
more than others
that you are able to scale the company
thank you for the inspiration i learned
so much and i love the companies that
you're invested and i'm honored that
we're co-investors in quite a few of
them and just looking at the list
company after company doing such such
amazing things for the world highly
profitable companies but at the same
time on the same on the same bottom line
doing doing some extraordinary things
for the world from ag tech to
organizational behavior to my to mental
well-being to anxiety relief all across
the board thank you very very much this
was a lot of fun
you